I've got something to say about the
other end of the substance spectrum the
Democrats and their media allies total
focus on scandal and obstruction
Democrats took the house last year
promising action on real issues that is
all gone now they're promising unending
investigation and obstruction they're
faithful cheerleaders in the media love
it new areas for investigators still
look Trump's tax returns impeaching the
president you thought this thing was
winding down turns out we're just
getting started
Falcone's testimony is the beginning of
the beginning of the first serious
congressional investigations of Donald
Trump Chuck Todd Rachel Maddow lawrence
O'Donnell and all the rest of them they
have disappeared right up their own
backsides they don't care about
substance they don't care about policy
they don't care about anything that
affects people's real lives they are the
definition of decadence isolated in
their establishment bubble zero empathy
for the struggles of working Americans
addicted to clickbait anti-trump Rhee
and the elitist obsessions of their
dinner party friends what an
embarrassment they are right I'm glad I
got that off my chest